[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est ce qu'on peut briser
excusez nous on se retrouve très vite et
bien bonjour à tous et à toutes ces
squeeze comme vous avez pu entendre
précédemment
je suis assez fier de moi d'avoir fait
ce petit mix audio faa a ok j'arrête
et donc on se retrouve aujourd'hui pour
une nouvelle vidéo commentée pas en live
sur call of duty donc 7 black ops donc
sur la map se mettent en démolition
encore une fois vraiment j'adore ce mode
de jeu et c'est un gros fail que vous
venez de voir j'ai sauté sur une clé
mort donc dans cette partie je vais
faire un score de 42 qu'il est de 12
morts donc je suis assez content de moi
encore une fois n'en croyez pas que je
fais que des bonnes parties je suis un
bon gros loser alors en fait pourquoi je
j'ai rejoint black ops donc vous vous en
doutez c'est une vidéo donc sur pc un
pas sur console car je n'ai pas déjà
lead hd pvr et en plus j'ai même pas le
jeu sur console donc pourquoi ben j'ai
acheté la xbox et je rejoue au bc bat
simplement parce que sur xbox je suis
une grosse qui on peut le dire un gros
loser de grosse merde
et puis donc bah ça jase j'ai vraiment
craqué psychologiquement c'était plus
fort que moi ok j'arrête
et donc j'ai dû j'ai dû pour ma santé
mentale et physique
oui parce qu'à force de taper sur mur
non je rigole j'ai dû donc retourner un
peu faire du du jeu sur pc et
franchement j'ai fait un bon petit
carnage ça m'a bien remonter le moral
parce que les scores vraiment tout le
temps négatif 1 je fais pas je fais
jamais de scores positifs sur consoles
j'en avais ras mes bonbons aux tagueurs
longer et donc est bon et ben voilà donc
ça a donné donc ce petit gameplay assez
sympa que je me suis empressé de filmer
après avoir après l'avoir fait donc on
arrête les longue intro pour it's a fait
déjà presque trois minutes
non deux minutes non attendez le curseur
je ne vois pas ok on s'en fout deux
minutes environ que je parle pour rien
dire
c'est génial là je rigole et puis donc
je voulais aussi vous remercier car on
attend les met hors mon fils s'est
emmêlé sur ma chienne ok bon tant pis il
en mêlée on va le laisser
excusez moi donc oui nos vies on atteint
les 20 mille vue pour le total de tout
mais vidéo c'est vraiment super je vous
remercie tous et toutes
vous êtes vraiment géniaux et aussi
mettez des votre vidéo préférée de moi
dans mon favori je peux vous affirmer
que ça favorise le partage vraiment ça
serait rarement coût de votre part de m
une de mes vidéos celle que vous
préférez dans mon favori voilà donc donc
dans cette partie là je suis donc en
défense et vous allez voir que avant moi
je vais vraiment drôlement bien joué mon
rôle je sais pas si c'est à ce round
aulas ou non donc là vraiment je en fait
là je joue pas tellement l'objectif au
début je me marre plus là tous les
ennemis passe par la gauche et par la
droite et par le haut par le bas n'a
rien pu dire ça et là attention le c4 1
1 je l'avais plus c'est vrai voilà donc
hélas et va être là donc je vais je vais
spawn jeu pauvre et je vais vraiment
faire un terrible carnage ne me semble
que c'est là c'est là que c'est pas là
que j'ai l'air d'un bon vol non si je
crois que ouais si voilà c'est donc là
j'en ai un
jocelyne centex ah oui ah ça fait penser
à ma toute première vidéo commentée un
deuxième en passant ou en fait peut-être
que je l'aract ivresse sur votre demande
où en fait passer une catastrophe je
décris tout ce qui se passe dans fin
c'est vraiment de la merde et enfin si
vous truc mais vidéo actuels ne sont pas
de la merde
enfin si vous trouvez que mes vidéos
actuels sont de la merde ne regarder
absolument pas cette toute première
vidéo car elle est vraiment
catastrophique je vais très bien dans la
description si vous voulez aller jeter
un coup d'oeil mais vraiment je vous
conseille vraiment pas donc ça va être
là je vais couper
sous l'escalier voilà l'ajmr alors vous
allez voir l'essai camouflé dans la
brume éternelle qui a fait leur succès
est donc voilà alors là c'est parti je
vais foncer comme un furax
je vais vouloir defuse be je sais que
j'y arrive pas aulas c'est ça ma
raquette la bombe c'est du racket c'est
du vol je me retourne jour honneur mais
quand est ce que je vais faire ma série
tu sais ce qu'il l'a enfin dans beaulieu
en allemand à la fin
enfin bon voilà bon pour le moment je me
fais vraiment plaisir d'enjeux ma classe
c'est donc le gall il avec un silencieux
en charger améliorer une c4 centex gaz
nova et comme à tous j'ai mis pillards
seigneurs de guerre et des marathons
voilà est ce vraiment une classe
polyvalente que j'apprécie beaucoup le
c4 est temps pour moi le meilleur
équipement rare polyvalence et le truc
vraiment le mec qui sert le plus dans le
jeu quoi les autres trucs sera peu elle
est comme on dit en anglais ok j'arrête
mais franchement je crois que j'attends
le record de kg rade dans cette vidéo je
n'arrête pas d'en faire ça devient
presque un ticket c'est assez énervant
pour vous je le suppose
voilà là j'allais encore une fois du
rocket j'arrête mais je vais pas dire
parce que j'aurais vraiment été bon donc
je la bats je continue je lance mon
petit gaza c'est vraiment utile ce super
eagles là franchement c'est vraiment
mais super méga uci le nombre de faux
j'ai tué des mecs avec le gaz quoi c'est
trop fort trop alors là je venais de
passer prestige 2 donc j'ai vraiment pas
le choix au niveau des arts gérant
beaucoup de choix et puis le guen lille
avec ce viseur holographique qui ce
silencieux m'a vraiment vraiment je dois
dire plus ah voilà c'est là là je suis
lancé alors regardez jeu quand mais d'un
côté je couvre france pas une excuse
mais n'a côté jeu cover bien les deux
points c'est un endroit ces stratégies
que je vous conseille à tous et à toutes
regardez donc là un premier arrive je le
tue tu es là j'essaie de bombarder avec
mon truc mais bon ça marchait pas donc
lui alors oui et complètement paumé de
la vie en parlant de peau mais j'avais
quelque chose de très important
alors là je fais une petite référence à
un pote je dirai pas ce nom c'est ça
c'est pas mais en fait il est un peu
paumé par exemple si on lui dit ouais
ludovic tu m'emmerdes j'ai dit son herbe
on n'en voulait pas ouais du lido vie
que tu peux me passer une à un moment
c'était play et la caisse qui répondent
eux pourquoi pas écouté de vie que parce
que puisque j'ai faim je vais manger de
bonbons mais pourquoi tu râles et ont
acheté vous et voilà il a un peu promet
mais bon il pose sur les questions un
peu conne mais bon franchement on l aime
bien comme il est il nous fait bien rire
à longueur de journée et vraiment il est
cool donc là je suis l'un cg plus beau
coup de main dans mon cas lille il me
reste que
voilà plus de balles et hélas pillards
est là pour nous d'ailleurs pourquoi il
a une forme d'oiseaux qu'on se pierre je
sais pas mais c'est un oiseau quoi que
ce soit bon ça se trouve c'est un bateau
alors lui le fail oh la la la la
qu'est-ce que ça me fait un sur deux
feuilles dures alors là avec le plus tôt
que je ne gère absolument pas alors lui
je me souviens que je vais le cut
fame et là hop je les ai j'enchaîne hop
le deuxième vraiment jolie comme un
enchaînement je trouve donc cette
fameuse haug
allez hop un petit dernier ars a
vraiment quelque chose de très joli
c'est quand vous tuez quelqu'un faisait
plus bas vous prenez son arme vous tuer
un autre vous avez la flemme de recharge
et vous reprenez son arbre vous
enchaînez comme ça les qu'il fit de
rechargement va veut appeler ça comme ça
ça doit vraiment vraiment être sympa
donc j'enchaîne avec un petit qu'il donc
lui il est allé se cacher se réfugie à
droite comme un insurgé a aussi
aujourd'hui en cours alors là
franchement j'aime bien raconter ma vie
pendant les vidéos commentées ok jazz et
donc j'étais en cours d'histoire et je
sais plus pourquoi ils nous disaient oui
donc ce sont les et là tout le monde j
les insurgés insurgés les insurgés et et
d'un coup on entend quelqu'un qui dit
les assauts de genre et avec mon pote
pendant je sais pas quinze bonnes
minutes ont été pliées sur notre table
de cours à rigoler comme des opcs et
j'arrête comme des nazes
pourquoi j'ai dit ok j'arrête je sais
pas vous mais ça devient presque un
chick mercenaires j'aime frapper non je
rigole
et donc voilà face à nous asservir et un
moment mais si le prof a dit jeu pour ce
que savait pas je m'appelle lucas
dans la vraie vie voilà donc encore de
moi je gagne et on voit pas les killcam
donc j'ai tout de suite les clés next kg
et donc j'ai donc disais bon allez
quelqu'un qui a pas parlé depuis tout le
court alors je vais demander ça qui est
là ils cherchaient dans sa tête elle à
mon pote arrêtait pas de faire du cas le
cas tout doucement pour le profane ah
oui tiens
lucas est là qu est ce qui fait au lieu
de dire le cas du café
tiens mon cousin s'appelle lucas et
l'âge on était plié on était pliée la
guinée dans toute la classe
on était mort de rire enfin bon c'est ma
vie j arrête un peu donc là vous allez
voir que je vais vraiment je objectif je
vais essayer d'amorcer a et b donc l'ua
oui il a juste dépassé sa tête c'est un
gros vilain bad boy que méchant pas
content et voilà annonce fallu que j'ai
pardon s'est accommodé du coa voilà là
quand même j'ai eu le c400 % skill bahia
squeeze lol j'arrête donc là j'avais
oublié que ça faisait un plongeon en
avant complètement débiles dans black
ops la boum ressemble à une valise
normal serment débile enfin mon jardin
critiqué et vous avez vu le code qui
tape il tape quelque chose comme 1 5 1 5
5 1 à 1,5
mais c'est quoi ce code franchement jeu
franchement vous amusez vous je passe
beaucoup de temps à regarder au ralenti
une séquence où quelqu'un pose là bon le
mec fait 1 5 5 1 à 1 5 5 1 1,5
normalement c'est complètement débile
comme code faim quant à une boum tu es
plutôt un truc à à 30 caractère 100 m 2
fois le même même si ce n'est pas
possible
enfin voilà corps bref et donc au niveau
de l'inspiration sûrement écoutez c'est
plutôt vide dans mon esprit et je sais
pas trop quoi faire comme vidéo c'est
pour ça que là je me disais à leur bon
gameplay
j'espère que ça a bien démarré à à son
fame enfin je reviens sur son fils après
un bon gameplay j'espère qu'ils vont
bien aimé
voilà parce que bon c'est vrai qu'en ce
moment là 15 des vidéos n'est pas au top
mais bon ça reviendra donc je disais le
type lâche pas si ça vous arrive à vous
aussi
par exemple vous vous prenez vous sauter
en l'air vous prenez trois balles et du
coup quand vous intéressez vous mourrez
c'est ballot ça nous énerve tout ce j'ai
dû rage quit plusieurs fois donc rage
quit pour ceux qui ne savent pas c'est
échappe quitter la partie oui ou start
quitter la partie oui c'est à dire que
vous barre de la partie alors lui-même
alors lui un ninja couteau alors là
franchement si je lui dis bravo c'est
regarde cette vidéo je lui dis bravo
franchement c'est vraiment c'était
vraiment sympa comme truc ce qui vous a
fait enfin bon donc comme le pont loby
c'est vraiment très bien passé je
remercie tous les joueurs donc qui était
là présent on s'est bien marré on a bien
fait des petites parts naïve et
puisqu'en fait c'est pas qu'une partie
c'est plusieurs parties on a joué en
ligne même après l'open lobby le lan non
je vous invite et on a continué un peu
de jouer pour certains d'entre vous
enfin bon c'était vraiment agréable
j'espère que l'open lobby sur pépé sur
pc va aussi bien se passer il aura lieu
mercredi à 16 heures je crois ouais 16
heures ouais ouais
césar est donc bah je vous invite à y
participer les joueurs pc si ce n'est
pas déjà fait puisque je vois rdpc on
est vraiment une me torelli torités une
minorité je regardais un dernière fois
sur le site de bad company 2 là il
affiche le nombre de joueurs par console
il ya 55 millions sur pc 4 1 millions
sur xbox et 85 millions sur ps3 voilà
pour vous de montrer à peu près les
chiffres qu'on n'est qu' un tiers de
vous nous les petits enfin bon voilà
donc là c'est bientôt la fin de la
partie
donc je pose la bombe désespérément
n'étant flasher
voilà enfin voila mon ces objets que
j'allais mourir et là je vais rocher
commun d'enfants non et je courrai comme
un tuyau votation les caisses je vais
prendre un peu de hauteur soit plus d'un
jour ok j'arrête c'est super lot est
donc alors là vous allez voir je tente
le tout pour le tout quand ça va
exploser je voulais savoir ce que je
vais faire je vais je vais d'ailleurs
tout de suite mettre un petit ralenti là
pour le fun pour que vous voyez bien ce
que je vais faire à la fin donc là je
fais une erreur de ces quatre donc je la
pète on appelle ça une c4
erreur fatale qu'est ce que ce monde ok
j'arrête
et donc là attention c'est la fin je
n'ai plus rien à perdre ou 360 double
switch to tatou grosse près random hélas
un pauvre type arrive et jules tu
essaies lelas quel âge aurait quitté la
partie met instantanément à la place de
ce type on regarde ça ah oui non c'est
vrai il n'ya pas de cliquer âme enfin
bon j'espère que vous avez bien aimé
cette vidéo commentée
écoutez je vous invite à vous abonner si
vous aimez bien ce que je fais un double
cliquer sur j'aime si vous aimez bien ce
que je fais et ajouter la vidéo dans vos
favoris si vous aimez bien ce que je
fais non ok j'arrête us supérieur
allez ciao tout le monde bail et à très
bientôt